最近始めの金遣い荒くなった気がする
5年前からですこんにちははじめ社長です
皆さん今来ているアプリなんだと思います
かそう
ティックトックであはじめ施設をやって
ますのでぜひフォローしてくださいね
ティックドック今やもう
鳥の井岡 v 競え最近はショートとかは
あるんですけども youtube てば
長い動画は中ティックとくっていうのは縦
動画でをパンパン
ブーバーしたあーそして今回ちょうー
どぅますどうぞ
[拍手]
[笑い]
ios じゃあ吊ら兄であるんですねぇ
youtube ですだけ時は弦にに来て
いただいております久しぶりねあーそれら
もう
2陣は youtube 止めて鳥居やん
だろうか
素敵とかピってのめっちゃまでぞーなんだ
弦逃げる youtube も楽しかった
けどなどとぞぉってのまたティック得と
いうテクとプライをしているイメージが
あるんですけどはい機と比べてどうな
どんな感じなんいやー結構楽しいですなか
僕ゲーっているスタイルは
ブーブー
ブーブーんですけどお母さんサングラスが
来たらええっ具材ロード5月るっていうか
あーいろいろえーっ
えっ377人くらいださんふらさですねえ
んで行ったら400円くらい大なるほどね
どんどん切っとくライブ中に下記アイテム
とかもらったらありがとうございますと
いう感じで遊べそれたい具材どうぞ僕は
モード喋ってるとちょっとかに来たもう
すぐに踊る no 前に竹ちゃん家で繊細
だ
面白い
思ってね最低が本題に入りましょう今時間
なんだかといいますと深夜の1時ですよ
大邱ドックライブ
さーん目がに新八はか撮ってるんじゃない
かと過疎ってます過疎ってるの突然テック
とクライムにパズル社長が工学科気合で
部分だけたらどうなるぞ
自分なんかそのいうのが痛いわけじゃない
んですけどあの仮にも多分ティックトック
ファイトになったら知ってるのかなくらい
の金持ってるか消えてもちょっとあげるの
でその人がちょっと嬉しいと思いますし
始め社長が突然課金アイテム投げたらどう
いう反応してくれるのがちょっと見てみ
たいと思います深夜のチェックだ
いや待てくっ
深夜のティックトックライブに争うカズ姐
軽い軽い
はいだけでさっそくやっていきましょう見
てください深夜だから早速ねだから配信し
てる奴おるやんでもこれこう人知ってるの
が youtube っていうかなぁ入っ
て危篤のバスケの動画上げてて結構見てる
で尿と好きでしょ
絹気づきちょいとで私たち今回のために
イェルプ30万課金してきました
やり過ぎなんだよなぁもったいないホテル
とかやれ30万円で15万濃いんだけど
半分に分ける熱帯になったら配属まず液面
投げるっていうあぁそうですね以上がいき
ますオールドちょっとっ
女てるよでられるなればちょっとその容器
に
ねぇされるためにそうでまずはしっかりと
チェックし飛ばしていきますさあ速しまし
た
フィットすごい
yeahうんっ
待ってっ
あっはじめシャツスーパーバッグ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ブーバー仕込みたけど本当に何かあっうん
これはめちゃくちゃ
ありがとうござい目覚め取れよめっちゃ長
1人はもうマジ寝ちゃう得だとメガネなぁ
もうあげなあ込めてごめんねおやすみ一
さんいるしました始め13ありがとう
ござい
みなさんすごい名前どう思うんでいき
ましょうマジであいらんじゃないなそう
ですな
よそれじゃあいいよいいよすごい色々ある
ねーそうだよ全然
それと衣に塩外なんだよ a
何猫耳と可能ですを築きますあっあとは
つくの月はすごいぞをしっかりとりて
いっぱい今ハイアーもどうぞ声よれうっ
ああああああ
でも野望 to burn れちゃっ
[音楽]
いやいやすごいやすごいよ21にしか見せ
ないからこういうのにもうちょっと分けて
みようかに低床高めだねこっじゃあ
ロケッツでも2万越えでは4万円かこれも
だいぶ m あすごいんだ皆盛り込みな
ボールますみな最高位げっ
さあ
これでタイミングですあなたのミラボの
寒いなぁ
none
ああいう気にするわけだこれ発足
[音楽]
始めた調査員
楊柳 sar
夏真っ
黄色れるありがとうんもえにょ対戦って
男女これはギフト対決です
けど僕れ数が多かっう多い方が勝つマティ
てあげるって事を想い起こった物体も秒
ジョジョしか出せて焼いよお前にアップ
始め社分のプライベートジェットだ意見人
は
母さんっでしょおっほんとあ
コースケ谷戸台公式だって
悦島結果があったんですじゃったんだって
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
襲っちゃってちゃうと
[音楽]
[拍手]
[笑い]
言葉にならない
いやーこれ1日半でございますいません
県内という
いっぱい送ってみていい里早この素敵な
男性には
メイクボックス起こりません
言えめぐっ
おりそけかわいいをはいい
なにこれえっ
化粧道具でで化粧どうぞそうなんですよ
希少どうなんだろうか家部分をそろそろ
化粧せーなーか思ってお年頃やから甘さを
ぞ願って
ゴリラフォローありがとう
尼崎のん辰巳買っちゃうっつー
か
君なもう来た来た住人でしちゃいまーぼこ
で理論所ではじめしたギフトしてる覚え
てるあロスコは以降どんどん色さあ始めた
じゃあねっを
ここには来ないでしょ
包んだよそれがいきますよ君にはスポーツ
からんっ
阪神ありがとうございますー心配していた
じゃっ
ピュッ
ほっハッハー
グループ
はじめしゃちょー
はいわばれーん
ブーバー腐ってろ
さあ
失笑良い
[音楽]
ブーブー言っはちょっと分いいですかこれ
をあげる声じゃないそれ4
ません
なあ hey
ん
それがいい
減配いただいの多い店皆さんいいねお願い
し mature ぬ島茶節炎ちょいや
人生いえっと韓国語はかけませんですね
[音楽]
次いきます神なんだいいいいじゃんはに7
人かこの時間とか1コス種死ぬ間にこのか
ターンいきますね心そうじゃないかなあ
あなたね山ずっちょましょうかなといき
ますよ
0に梅松鶴のはすごいかわいいあれが
なかったんでそうに言われちゃって a 杭
多いそう
おばすごい
えっ
あっはえっ
えあれから ai 円全面安となるん
でしょ
えっ
マジっすかぁ me to do a
i n
フェチおおっ
やそんな男あれやめてくださいって感じ
すくってカチッねえっえっ
品は arsa でっを野生の本でくれる
ねー
こういうきっとかいいけど指諦めて
ください26人見てるのでここぞと言って
みたいと思います
ますやっぱ女の子なのでそろそろちょっと
ぶっこんでていいもう意味たちには待って
あげましょう25000行為なので3万円
ぐらいかいきますよ
フィぎゅっと
[音楽]
もうすごい
そう
ありがとーっ
[音楽]
6中山じゃないこれ惑星ません栽培
けどん
ね何誰
この人始め私だ
n 乗院だけど多いんだけど
れたけどさはじめぬさあありついてない
まっ何の惑星
安いせないぞねまだ
ありえないですのでこんな時間に
えっ夏連覇信じられないのかなーでそう
ですよおかしいんんなあこれやっぱ信じ
ウワアアアアア
ああよく良かった
ああいやあちょっと神じゃないんだいや
信じら信じないよだってちょっと気づいて
色塗っ
ちょっとの課題のこれで粘ら分野いいん
ですけど
4 aこのようにを見よう
おねずみみたいなかで見たいのかと見たい
のか明さんはシャイな感じだろうかお前
ライオンを送ってる大丈夫6万円くらいか
スコア当ててます事件
連想する妹ちょさあ目覚めよう野生の本能
そして木場事務所長ハトメ子だなぁん
おはよう
始めて何
俺だ
初めての割に求めちゃう java 市松
1回まで1対3のチケ一家を助けない読ん
でば高い理由やめっちゃくちゃたよねそう
すぎ
初めてのでこれから誰か
ああああああぶー
[音楽]
ぶーっ
重い
バッハございません
きました
いましたダッカキー女の仲間ですちょっと
くらいので皆ボルダーからフック照らして
あげたいところでは
あーからかわいい12は軽くなってるん
ですよねじゃあええええ
[音楽]
hey 何一紗緒
a
笑は line やっちゃったとか
n
小針いっ
朝離さない何もっっ
のに
これで山を築かれていました
もしもして
a なにゃんあると話してない
私のことパブロ明かそうとしたいの a
runner んことだ感想なんかじゃ
ないんですけど全然はい端であ私今
心持ってかれそうねあーやんだな
その作ったからミラーボールつけて
くださったじゃあちょっと素敵な
リアクションいただけたので最後食べに
行こう名前変わっかぁあああ
あいくぞはできるだけにませんもうお金的
にこれからそんな人にいいことしてなかっ
いえことっていうのかな
盗んで切り舞う
世界にひらめっ
あもう通知がしてるん
何えなによと話しました恩を少し
あ
会えたねプロポーズかんな
なかなか美味しい
ぶー
[音楽]
打ったあっちょ